we have we have hundreds and hundreds of
affidavits of stories that are even
worse than the stories I'm hearing
why wouldn't they overturn an election
certainly overturn it in your state
because we have other states that are
just as bad if you look at uh Michigan
with Detroit you look at the things that
happened in Detroit
where you have a voter
but you have more votes
that you have voters
you take a look at Detroit Michigan you
have more votes than you have voters and
then you have two people that don't want
to certify they don't want to certify
and they're harassed violently and they
turned off the cameras during the
harassment for two hours
and then they said wow and they were
afraid and they voted and then they went
back to sign and they couldn't do it
because they said we can't do it because
this is corrupt this is horrible what's
taking place think of it more votes than
you have voters but that was the least
of it they have things that were as bad
as that and this is going on all over
all over we're doing very well and a lot
of States a lot of good things are
happening in Georgia we're getting
Little Help from government but a lot of
good things are happening in Georgia
Wisconsin and uh Michigan if they're
seeing what happened in Detroit
and we sure are looking at what's
happening in Pennsylvania and
Philadelphia what happened in
Philadelphia they keep the poll watches
not only in pens but they keep them out
of the building
and the only reason they got back into
the building was they got a court order
and then the definition of back into the
building was very far away where they
couldn't see anything and they talked
about closed circuit television except
you couldn't see it because the picture
was so unclean you didn't even know what
they were doing they could have been
playing a baseball game
so it's a very sad thing for our country
to have this and they have to turn over
the results it would be easy for me to
say oh let's worry about four years from
now no this election
was lost by the Democrats they cheated
it was a fraudulent election they
flooded the market they deported
everybody invalid
for being there you're doing a
tremendous serve this is a very
important moment in the history of our
country and you're doing a tremendous
service to our country and don't worry
about bravery because the people that
talk the most they're not the ones you
have to worry about and these are all
talkers they intimidate but these are
not people that you can ultimately have
to they push you around they push our
poll workers out our poll Watchers were
pushed out of the building
okay some got back in they were put in
the pens but these are not people don't
be intimidated by these people but
they're bad people they're horrible
people and they're people that don't
love our country so we don't have to
worry about four years right now we have
to worry what happened on November 3rd
and previous to November 3rd and by the
way after November 3rd when people put
votes in and they put them in
illegally they put them in after the
polls closed and one of our great
Supreme Court Justices made mention of
that and I can't imagine that any
justice or anybody looking at it could
be thrilled when they vote after the
election is over so I want to thank
everybody very much for being there I
want to thank
the state senate respected people
tremendous people and you're doing a
tremendous service for our country and
if something was done wrong if this
election was Was Won fraudulently and
that's what happened it was a fraud and
we're talking about very importantly
many more ballots many more votes than
the number we need in other words if
a thousand votes we're not talking about
we found nine dead people that voted of
course there were many more than that
many numbers that nobody even believes
now we're talking about numbers that are
far in excess of the fifty thousand far
in excess of another state where we lost
by ten thousand and they went absolutely
wild because we got far more votes than
they thought possible and they've just
stepped in the gas and they got caught
just like they got caught spying on my
campaign they got caught exactly they
got caught doing this so I really
appreciate it and the country
appreciates it and we have to turn the
election over because there's no doubt
we have all the evidence we have all the
affidavits we have everything all we
need is to have some judge listen to it
properly without
having a political opinion or having
another kind of a problem because we
have everything and by the way the
evidence is pouring in now as we speak
and I want to thank Rudy Giuliani for
Having the courage to do this
[Applause]
that are being screamed at Rudy is a is
the greatest mayor in the history of New
York and there's a reason he's got great
courage and he doesn't care he wants to
do what's right and I told him the other
day Rudy you were the greatest mayor in
the history of New York and you see what
happened to New York without Rudy you
were the greatest mayor but this is more
important what you're doing now is far
more important than being a great mayor
of the city of New York and being its
greatest mayor by far by the way by far
this is going to be your crowning
achievements because you're saving our
country thank you all very much thank
you
all right
I think what you've just heard
guarantees that a hundred years from now
that this is the most important public
hearing ever held by the senate
committee
[Applause]